German scientists have invented a material
that can conceal any object known to man.
This will only be used for good....I hope.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if it
isn't obvious already, the future is amazing.
We have self-driving cars, we have robots
that can dance and sing.
But you know what we don't have enough of?
Invisibility cloaks.
Until now - cause we JUST invented one.
The fine people over at the Karlsruhe Institute
of Technology in Germany have created a polymer
that can make any object invisible to the
sense of touch.
So when you lay it over something, it perfectly
adapts and absorbs the shape of whatever's
underneath it.
This example photo shows a tiny metal cylinder,
encased in this polymer - so no matter how
hard you press down on it, you won't be able
to feel the cylinder underneath.
The polymer itself consists of a bunch of
tiny needle-shaped cones, whose tips meet
to form a crystalline structure that encases
an object and makes it completely impervious
to detection.
Even a force feedback mechanism won't be able
to determine the object hidden underneath.
What's even cooler, is that each of those
tiny cones is constructed with sub-micrometer
accuracy, so by changing the size of the contact
points - you can theoretically create a material
with any kind of mechanical properties you
want.
Even those not found in nature.
The researchers who invented this say it was
developed purely for experimental purposes
- but it does open up ideas for some interesting
new applications.
One example they give - that I could totally
see myself using - is for camping.
If you created a very thin mattress out of
this meta-material, it could completely absorb
all of the twigs and jagged rocks underneath
it - so you'd have a completely smooth surface,
with no indication you were even sleeping
on the ground.
Of course, this IS brand new - so practical
applications are still a long ways off.
But still!
Just think of all the things we could do with
this!
I'm sure you guys have some awesome suggestions,
so as long as they don't involve couch cushions
and several kilos of cocaine, feel free to
share em!
Just leave em in the comments below, or you
can hit me up on Twitter at @TaraLongest.
That's all for me, but as always - thank you
guys for watching!